a medida que el llamado convoy de la
libertad atrae críticas de la policía de
ottawa las protestas de los camioneros
por los mandatos de vacunas se están
extendiendo desde la capital canadiense
a otras ciudades este fin de semana en
toronto las fuerzas de seguridad
intentan frenar los cierres la protesta
comenzó hace una semana por el mandato
de la vacuna kobe 19 para cruzar la
frontera entre eeuu y canadá
algunos insisten en que el primer
ministro liberal ya está instruido sea
depuesto con el argumento de que excedió
su autoridad al imponer restricciones
contra la pandemia
el movimiento produce frustración entre
algunos residentes de ottawa el ruido de
bocinas y en algunos casos acoso las
autoridades siguen pidiendo a los
manifestantes que abandonen las calles
pido a los manifestantes ahora que han
presentado sus argumentos que regresen a
casa que apelen ante sus autoridades sus
representantes electos para que
continúen defendiendo sus puntos de
vista así es como hacemos las cosas en
canadá los organizadores del convoy de
la libertad habían recaudado unos 8
millones de dólares estadounidenses pero
el viernes la plataforma de donaciones
web code fan me eliminó la página de
recaudación de los manifestantes
argumentando violaciones en sus términos
de servicio